old accusations in the new forum tonight
The Wall Street Journal reporting on
what it says was president Trump's
direct involvement in hush money payoffs
to women alleging sexual involvement
payments that could be illegal
correspondent Kevin cork has details
tonight from the White House could even
Kevin evening Bret the president
violated campaign finance laws that
according to The Wall Street Journal in
fact they say they have evidence to
prove it a very interesting story a bit
of a blockbuster coming out this evening
let me share just a bit of what the Wall
Street Journal is saying this evening in
that report it is a lengthy report it
says among other things that it is
essentially refuting the president his
legal team and advisors who have all
denied that the President had any
involvement in hush money payoffs to
former adult form film performer stormy
Daniels and another woman during the
2016 campaign through its investigation
the journal speculates Brett that this
now raises the possibility that the
president violated federal campaign
finance laws because it claims mr. Trump
was involved in or briefed on nearly
every step of the hush money
arrangements and the agreements they're
alleging that he engaged in or directed
the deals by telephone and/or in
meetings with his self-described fixer
Michael Cohen now much of this actually
comes by way of evidence gathered by the
Southern District of New York the US
Attorney's Office there in Manhattan
using recordings made by mr. Cohen and
you may recall that they actually
extracted a guilty plea from mr. Cohen
the president's former fixer back in
August they convicted him of campaign
finance law violations alleging
coordination of those payments through
conversations or meetings with one or
more members of the Trump campaign team
that one person according to the report
or at least suggested that that person
was in fact the President himself now
aside from the president's denials we do
know the White House has offered a
series of denials about his involvement
in the circumstance you may recall
earlier in the year White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders said none of
these allegations are true that of
course is back in March then in May we
also heard Rudy Giuliani described
Cohen's payments to Daniels as quote
well the president paid him back no
campaign finance violations no crime of
Michael that's Coen had discretion to
solve these as in these problems now
Brett you also know this or sometime now
we have heard that Jay Sekulow would
field response about this circumstance
we have not heard back from him on this
latest report in The Wall Street Journal
but of course should we hear from him
I'll be sure to pass it along but for
now back to you Kevin quark live in the
North Lawn Kevin thanks